Memphis Police director CJ Davis
describes the officer's actions as
heinous Reckless and inhumane Davis says
she could only stomach watching the
video Once in an interview with our Jeff
pigays Davis says she still doesn't
understand why the officers went so far
yes very puzzling for me that I don't
have the information that I need to at
least understand what started this it
started at a 10.
know from the moment they got out of
their cars
and that peace I've never seen before
the similarity for me with Rodney King
and I was an officer back during that
time too
that came to mind for me on this video
to me there was a level of group think
you know that there was no one that you
know isolated themselves or stepped out
to say stop we got him or whatever the
case is that's enough
Davis added more questions to the
investigation pointing out that one of
the officers failed to turn on their
body camera and that the officer that
made the initial traffic stop did not
call it in over the radio